We're going to be using Google Chrome
and Google Chrome developer tools or dev tools,
throughout this course. And I recommend that you
actually use Chrome Canary. Which has all of
the latest and greatest development tools built in.
And one more thing, when we capture all
of our traces. I recommend that you use
your phone, to actually capture the profiling data.
>> Mm. Well, that makes sense. But, how do I capture this data with my phone?
>> Great question. For the remainder
of this lesson, you're going to get some
instructions from Peter Lovers, on how to
set up mobile debugging. And if you're already familiar, feel free to skip ahead